uh my name is amjit ramanajam and
i'm here to talk about awesome command
line tools
about five years ago i started a site
project called pgcli which is a um a
command line client for postgres
databases it had auto completion and
syntax highlighting from the terminal
and since then
it has grown into a github organization
called dbcli with clients for a bunch of
different databases such as mysql mssql
server sqlite and redis
there are many more actually if you
visit wcli.com you'll see them and this
talk is a
is going to walk you through some of the
design decisions that made these tools
successful
and i obviously took inspiration from a
lot of existing well-designed command
line applications
and i'm going to try and summarize what
those well-designed command lines uh
tools did different than the others that
didn't do as well
but before we get started into actually
jumping into the into the
various design decisions i want to tell
you about my own journey so i started i
was introduced to computers in about 20
years ago and i was using ms-dos that
was my first command line introduction
and
during those days we didn't have stack
overflow so i wasn't
able to just simply copy and paste the
command into the into the prompt to
check out what it did instead we used to
thumb through a a book or a manual and
whenever we saw a command that seemed
interesting like you know i don't know
format c colon or something we would try
it out on the on the prompt
the issue there is that i was not a very
good typer um i would make typos and
anytime i made a mistake i had to retype
the entire command from the beginning
this took a very uh you know this took a
lot of time and at that time my teacher
took pity at me and he said that you
know there is this thing called
command history navigation if you were
to press the up arrow key it will bring
up the previous command that you have
typed and you could fix the typo and
then press enter to make that command
run
and this was such a joyous occasion for
me because i obviously was awful at
typing and this saved me a bunch of time
and later when i was introduced to linux
in my grad school
i found out that bash also allowed me to
navigate the history using the up arrow
and the down arrow but when i was
pairing with a friend of mine i noticed
that he was able to complete file names
and paths at a lightning speed
a speed that i've never seen before
anyone type so i asked him about it and
he said and he introduced to me the
concept called tab completion which is
when i type a prefix of a path or a file
name and i hit the tab key bash will
auto complete the rest of the file name
for me
i didn't have to type the entire thing
once again this was a great day for me
even though i had now learned how to
touch type and i was typing at a furious
speed of 55 words per minute
now the point of the moral of the story
is not that command lines have awesome
features they do and that's fantastic
the problem is that it is hard to
discover them on your own unless a
friend introduces to you or a mentor
introduces to you um or you go read
about it in a man page which is a
different program than the program that
you're trying to use it is
it is very hard to stumble upon them
accidentally yourself
so discoverability how do we solve this
well let's take a look at let's take a
and
look at some of the gui applications and
how they solve this
any new any new version of the existing
gui tool is released and
all the new features typically tend to
get a icon in the in the toolbar or a
entry in the menu
and being humans we are curious and we
look at a new button and we tend to go
and poke at it and that's a great way to
discover these new new features but
command line applications lack this
ability they don't have a way where you
could automatically show a icon or some
kind of a toolbar or anything like that
because command lines are are very
spartan in their
in their appearance so what can we do so
let's take a look at pgcli this is the
the tool that i talked about which is a
postgres client for uh
from the command line and how did we
solve the discoverability issue in pgcli
so i briefly talked to you about
okay i briefly talked to you about
uh tab completion i have just connected
to a postgres database using pgcli and
when i start to type so this since this
is connected to a database i'm going to
run a sql query and as soon as i start
to type se i notice that there is a
pop-up menu and then it gives me all the
options that are available for
that start that happen to start with the
se
prefix
so now i could i could simply go down
the menu to select star from and all of
these are available so this is what i
mean where i didn't have to press a tab
key in order to trigger the completion
the trip the auto completion was
available to me as soon as i started
typing them
this is a simple way in which
discoverability was one of the
discoverability issues was solved in
pgcli
for the next one i want to show you fish
shell now if you have used bash or z
shell you might already be aware of this
little key binding which is pressing
ctrl r allows you to search through your
history and
what you do is you press ctrl r and you
start to type a little portion of the
command that you may have typed some
time in the past and it will search
through the history and then it will try
to find the command that has the little
portion of the string that you have
typed and it'll bring that up for you so
you don't have to type the entire thing
once you have found this little key a
key binding you will never type a
command without control r because there
is a good chance that you have typed a
command already and you are simply
trying to recover it from history so you
always type control r and then you would
type the portion such as ssh into a host
or you're
making a new virtual environment or the
cd into a particularly long path or
something
you could do all of those things using
control r now fish shell goes a step
further it surfaces this this sort of
history navigation and it's best if i
show if i showed it to you in a
quick demo
now this is what fixture looks like it's
just an alternative shell for bash or z
shell and
if i start to type let's say i do cd and
you'll see that
it automatically fills in a
a folder name for me because it knows
that this is a command that i have typed
previously and it automatically pops it
up for me and i could press the right
arrow key to fill the rest of it for me
this is particularly useful if you have
if you ssh into multiple hosts in your
in your day-to-day job for instance
earlier today is etched into a into a
particular machine and i would like to
assist it back into it instead of trying
to find the host name i could just type
ssh and it autofills the the name for me
and if this is not the host that i'm
interested in i could press the up arrow
key and then it will search through the
various ssh commands that i have typed
in the past and it will automatically
provide them for me and i could choose
the one that i need to ssh into
this is another clever way that fish was
able to solve the issue of history
navigation rather than binding it to a
key key binding it was able to
automatically surface that when it was
needed and
right at the time when we would need
that
so
the point of discoverability is that we
want to make it easy for the user to
find the features that the fantastic
features that command line tools have
built in how can we do that well there
are two things you could do one is be
more forthcoming what i mean by that is
as soon as a feature becomes applicable
to a particular scenario surface that
feature right away rather than waiting
for the user to press a trigger it using
a tab key or a or some kind of a special
key so do not hide your features behind
some kind of a special key but instead
make it more forthcoming and make it
more make it available as soon as it's
um it makes sense or it's appropriate
for that situation that's how we solve
discoverability is in some of the the
tools that we have built
now the the second feature that i would
like to talk about for the command line
applications is user focus now this is
not just for command line tools this is
this should be for any kind of a
interface user interface at all but
the the point behind user focus is that
users come first usually when you are
trying to implement a program you would
automatically try to optimize in a way
where it is easier for you to develop
the code it is easier for you to um to
iterate on it and so forth but i think
that should always take a back seat to
how it should it should feel for the
user so build the interface that is most
powerful for the user most intuitive for
the user and then worry about how to
implement it how about going to
implement it
i want to give you a quick example a
demonstration of what that would look
like so i'm going to take a second
application called mycli which is a
mysql command line client which is very
similar to pgcli
that talks to the mysql database now
before i show you my cl i want to show
you the default mysql client
mysql and i'm connecting to a particular
database called world
and once i log into the database i type
sel and i hit the tab key in fact i am
hitting the tab key you may not be able
to see this
but there is no auto completion which is
surprising
all right let's try it again with
uppercase and now i hit the tab key and
there is autocompletion available and
this is what i mean by user focus which
is the user the the programmer for mysql
could have made a simple choice where to
make the auto completion case
insensitive
but it was more convenient for them to
have to change it from uppercase to
lowercase or lowercase to uppercase in
order to show the completion so instead
they are forcing the user to to type it
all in uppercase
which is a very poor choice that that
was made and and further that if i do
select start from and then i hit tab
again
it's asking me if i would like to see
805 possibilities which is very
surprising because this is a small
database that i uh created just for this
demo which has three tables at most and
so 805 is a bit surprising because after
from keyword you always have a table
name so i press yes to see all the all
the available options and it's giving me
every single keyword that mysql has in
its repository instead of providing me
just the table names
which is again a very unfortunate uh way
to interact with the user
now let's contrast that to my cli i'm
connecting to my cli and i'm doing the
connection to the exact same database
and when i do that and i start to type
sel
you will notice that it immediately pops
up
pops up the
autocompletion pop-up for me
and it also seems to be providing the
fish style auto suggestion towards the
end but we'll get get to that in just a
minute
now if the user were to use all caps
what happens let's see s-e-l and it
still gives them gives them the option
to to autocomplete it for them
and at this time the autocompletion is
presented with all caps
it knows that the user prefers to to use
uppercase and so it provides auto
completion in uppercase rather than
providing it in the lowercase
and then if i go further and then i do
select start from and then i hit the tab
key i notice that it is only giving me
the three tables that are in this
database because after from keyword you
can only fill in a table name
and so
i do that and it goes even further if i
wanted to add a where clause
it gives me just the column names inside
of that particular table it doesn't give
me everything under the sum
and then i could do any population over
500 and
here are all the all the
cities
now this is a clear use of how the user
focus comes first in the implementation
second because when i first implemented
pgcli in fact i took the same approach
that mysql was taking which was i would
complete i would show completion for
every single keyword every single table
every single column in that database and
the user has to type in in order to
narrow down that completion menu to find
out what they they're actually looking
for and when i showed it to a couple of
uh early users or some of my friends
they told me how um how inconvenient it
was it it gave them the illusion that it
was going to do something smart but then
instead it gave them the list of
everything and they had to type in the
whole name in order to figure this out
so it took me another month so to just
write the completion
engine for sql
so that i could make this thing work
where it provided this context-sensitive
auto-completion now that is a large
undertaking you might think but it is
totally worth it because that's what
made these projects actually a success
and so that's what i mean by by user
focus
user always comes first and
implementation later do not focus on the
implementation do not try to make it
easy for you to implement some feature
make it easy for the user to make it
more intuitive and make it more powerful
and the next tool that i would like to
showcase for you is called b python this
is a alternative python interpreter
that comes with autocompletion again and
let me show you what that does so before
again before i show b python i want to
show you just python repo and this is
the
standard default python repo i type imp
and i hit tab and it gives me import and
i'd like to import requests module i
type req and then i hit the tab key and
it does not give me the module names but
instead it's providing me with the the
functions that the built-in functions
are available
it's
it's kind of it suffers from the same
problem that the mysql was uh having
which was it's not context sensitive
completion but
let's take it even further so i do
request and then i want to call requests
get
and i hit the tab key and it inserts a
tab character into the into the code
obviously python does
there is no use for tab key in a python
code so this makes absolutely no sense
let's contrast that with uh the python
and see how that does here again i do
imp it gives me import in a little
pop-up menu i i fill that in and i do re
and it automatically gives me just the
modules and i see requests as one of the
available options and so i import
requests
and then i go in and i do request dot
and it gives me a list of all the
all the methods that i can call on this
module i do get and i open a bracket and
it not only gives me the arguments for
that function but it also pulls up the
docs string for that particular method
which means i don't ever have to leave
my python repel to find out how to use
this use this particular method i don't
have to open a separate browser window
to read about the documentation or even
to call help on this particular method
to see the doc string it is available
right when i need it it doesn't pop it
up any any time before that but right
when i'm when i'm about to give it the
arguments it tells me url what does url
mean and what are the params and what
are the return type and so forth
so that
so that
some of you might argue that this type
of auto completion or this type of um
documentation uh information
can be made available in the in the
default python interpreter by adding a
little python rc file
now my argument to that is
configurability is the root of all evil
this might seem like a bit of an
exaggeration but
whenever your your program introduces a
con new configuration option
it is simply because the program is not
smart enough to figure out what is the
right thing to do for the user by
default it should ship with sensible
defaults it should not require
configurations for the simplest things
where it can figure out what is the best
available option for the user is
now i'm not arguing that configuration
all configuration is bad there are some
configuration that is absolutely
required for instance
choosing a color scheme this is a very
subjective
choice this is based on someone's taste
somebody likes dark configuration dark
color schemes some some other folks like
the light color schemes and that should
absolutely be a configuration option but
having the auto completion and or having
the history navigation using the fish
style history navigation those things
should not be configuration options but
instead they should be defaults that
start up with that
okay so
what that means is whenever you are
building an application and you want to
build a config file
make the config file only have the
options that are subjective
taste based options
we talked about discoverability user
focus and configurability and you and i
showed demos from fish shell b python
pgcl and mycli
at this time you might be thinking i
found a bunch of new tools that i could
use in my day-to-day workflow which is
great and these seem to be you know good
replacements for the existing default
tools and i'll go and use them but if i
were to write my own command line client
uh implementing all these auto
completion or these history navigations
fish
fish style suggestion seems a bit of an
overkill or it's going to take more time
than than i could i could spend on my on
my projects so when i if i have to write
something at work or as a side project
for myself i probably won't use this use
these things to build it in my own
now
you might think that these are hard
features to implement but what if i told
you that you could implement all of
these in mere 10 minutes
and in in simply 10 lines of python code
in fact i'm going to do that for you
right now in live
the this is a checklist that i typically
use uh the the checklist that i use has
is that a any command line application
should have a persistent history what
what i mean by this is any commands that
i type into a particular session after i
quit this and then i go back to the
application the history should be
preserved so i should be able to press
the up arrow to see what the last
command that i typed or the previous
command and so forth and i should be
able to search through this history
either using the control r key because
that is now kind of ubiquitous and
everybody knows about it or using the
fish style auto suggestion where it
suggests things from the history itself
and in addition to that it should also
have emax key bindings which is if you
press ctrl a in your bash prompt it
takes you to the beginning of the line
control e takes you to the end of the
line and control b takes you one
character at a time
just takes you back one character at a
time and control f takes you forward one
character at a time and so forth but
this has become a
a common
key binding that is available in most
command line applications and i think
any command line application that you
build should build this in as as the
users have come to expect this
and auto completion and syntax
highlighting are what give joy to a user
when they are using a particular
application so let's build all let's
build all of this in about
in about 10 minutes now i'm going to use
a library called prompt toolkit it is
written by jonathan slenders and this is
the library that is used in pgcli myself
and in fact all of the tools that i um
that are under the dbcli organization
and i'm going to use that library to
build a repo a reply stands for read
eval print and loop and what this means
is you read the user input you evaluate
the input and you print the results of
that evaluation and then you go back
and ask the user for the next input
that's what a wrapper is so python uh
when you type python and you hit enter
and you go into a little uh
interpreter that is a reply because it's
asking for the user input evaluates
whatever you have typed and then prints
the results if there is any result and
then it goes back to asking you for the
next input now we're going to do the
exact same thing here
i have a split window and i'm going to
create a brand new file called reply it
is absolutely blank
and
on the right side i'm going to
try and run this program every time i
change something on the left side
now if it was a regular standard python
repo
i would i would use if i'm using just
default python then i would use input
and store that into a variable whatever
the user has typed give it a little
prompt perhaps like that
and that will ask the user for an input
and store whatever value comes back as
the inp into the inp variable now we're
not building any kind of a regular
repo we are building an awesome rebel so
in order to do that we're going to
import
prompt token and use that
from toolkit import prompt
and instead of using
input i'm going to use prompt
and i mentioned that it has to continue
to ask the user for multiple inputs so
i'm going to put this inside a while
loop
and
rebel has to evaluate it and print the
results in this case i'm going to skip
the evaluation and then print right back
to the user whatever they have typed so
i'm
it is let us call this a
echo repel which is whatever the user
has typed in
um it will print it back to the user
and with about four lines of code we
were able to build a simple repo now
it's asking us for an input we could
type hello
world
i can press the up arrow nothing happens
because there is no history built into
it
i can type a select command
and if i press control a and ctrl e that
seems to work control b is working
control f is working
and so forth so
without much effort we have added key
bindings by simply replacing the input
with the prompt
if i press ctrl d it quits but it quits
within trace back and the reason there
is a traceback is because all i have to
do is catch that exception and quit
gracefully we can do that in a at a
later time but uh for the sake of
simplicity of the code i'm not going to
add the try
except clause here
now the second thing we want to do is
add a persistent history once again
we're going to use prompt toolkit to do
that
i mentioned that we want to have
a persistent history and so i would like
to use the file based history
so that when i quit the
application it saves the history in a
separate file
the way to do that is i add a new
history
keyword and i give it a file history
and i give it a file name let's call it
history here
now if i were to run this again
i do hello world and i press the up
arrow and i have history
and i can do the select star from abc
and now if i press ctrl r i have reverse
search that's available so i could type
in world and i get world
or i could press select
i get select
and if i quit and now if i come back to
the repel one more time
and i still have the history available
so this is what a persistent history is
supposed to do because it persists
between
program restarts now that's history
but
using using control r is nice and all
but we would like to have fish style
completion because we talked so much
about it so let's do that as well
import
what i suggest from history
and here i do audit suggest equals auto
suggest from history
now i quit and i relaunch it again and
now if i start to type the select
statement i see the the autocompletion
auto suggestion automatically giving me
that i have already typed the select
statement in the history and so i could
just press the right arrow key and get
it filled in for me and that is how we
add auto suggestion with a single line
that we added to the code
now let's add a completer so that it can
pop up without having to press a tab key
what possible completions are available
so again the prompt toolkit has a
completion engine that is built in and
we can do a word completer and what word
computer does is if we give it a list of
words and we start to type
any kind of letter in the in the prompt
it will try to look through the list of
words that we have and then it will
automatically try to match whichever
word matches with whatever we have typed
so far so that's a word computer and
since i'm pressing i'm typing
select statements uh let us try and use
use build this as an sql completer
so we give it a list of sql keywords so
let's give it select
show
from
[Music]
where
tables
and since i made such a big deal about
my sql not being a case insensitive
completer i'm going to set the ignore
case to true so that hours it can be a
smarter completion engine
so i do a completer equals sql completer
and let's try this again
relaunching this and i do s and
immediately a computer pops up for me i
can do show
tables and there we go
and
so this this now gives me
so let's start from abc
where
def
equals ghi
so
we've already built ourselves a nice
little ripple that provides us with auto
completion auto suggestion persistent
history
one other thing that we had in the list
was syntax highlighting let's see if we
could add that now syntax highlighting
is going to be provided by pigments
which is another third-party library
that has built-in auto syntax
highlighting for a bunch of different
um
different
[Music]
languages out there so i'm going to take
one of the pigments autocompleter and
i'm going to use that with prompt
toolkit so from took it has the ability
to take in multiple lectures uh which
can auto which can syntax highlight and
it has built-in ability to do the the
pigments highlighting
so from pigments
import
actually pigments dot lexers
sql import sql
flexor
and then again i add the next one where
i say lecture equals
pigments lecture of
sql
alexa
and
now if i go back and relaunch this and
if i do the sel and i'm going to use the
auto suggestion to automatically fill it
for me and there it is it is
syntax highlighted for me where the
where the the coded string is is clearly
syntax i'll add it if i remove it it
doesn't syntax allow it for me and so i
can i can do it again and so forth so
that is all it took for us to build a
autocompleting
autocompleting
repo
i did say that we would be able to do
this in 10 lines of code i did take 18
lines but let's uh let's make this
sorry
let's make the code slightly ugly
here we go voila 10 lines of code
so if i did not bother with white spaces
then i could build a
a reply in 10 lines of python code
and let's uh so this is the code that i
just typed in case i choked on the live
demo
so in the checklist we were able to
implement persistent history history
search emacs key binding auto completion
in fact we did not have any
configuration at all so that qualifies
as minimal config
and we added syntax highlighting at the
very end
so the resources that i covered today
are dbcli which is the github
organization and that has multiple
clients inside of it we have pgcli
cli light cli for sqlite and there's
even a redis client called iretis
and i talked about fish shell which has
a fantastic design philosophy document
which i take inspiration from quite a
bit
that you should check out and i
mentioned uh b python which is my
favorite python record that i use on a
daily basis and i also talked about
prompts toolkit which is a library that
allows us to build these rich command
line applications with auto completion
and auto suggestion and so forth
thank